[Music]
tonight on NBC it's a double dose of
Jennifer Hudson first on the voice been
on a very pentatonix Christmas only et
was on the set with Jennifer who is the
definition of a working mom
one minute I'm sending a chair on the
voice in the next second I made my son's
school like not what's going on you know
do you walk into school like that yes
and it's not Jennifer Hudson's
motherhood then like I have to see
what's going on with my baby but her
baby eight year old David is growing up
fast he's a big boy now
so he says mommy stay inside so I watch
him and then he walks himself to the bus
stop Wow as for her day job on The Voice
I'm kinda overly passionate about it I
don't know if y'all noticed but I have
you stand out and he's like I never seen
nothing like this and this bike oh well
welcome to Jay high productions you'll
be hearing Jennifer tonight after the
boys on pentatonix second annual
Christmas special
I stopped by as she recorded her duet
with the a cappella group
[Applause]
pendens onyx and i met this past summer
and it event that we performed it
together and we kind of like fell in
love with each other actually when I was
a kid I want a competition to sing with
her the whole tree line flew broke out
and all their dating would you guys ever
have pentatonix on the voice oh my god I
think that would be a nice maybe should
be my mentors or something that would
bring a whole nother element of music
yeah Adam and Blake don't know nothing
about that I'm sure of it